[Music]
artist bisa butler has been called a
modern day griot but instead of using
words to tell stories she uses stitches
and cloth her quilts have graced the
covers of magazines and she created the
striking illustration for the soon to be
released book unbound the memoir of
activist and metoo movement founder
tarana burke nancy chen spoke to butler
about creating a new narrative using
fabric
her vividly detailed portraits often
reimagine the lives of those they
portray
and now beast of butler's life itself is
launching in a new direction
seeing my artwork at home and in my
studio is one thing but seeing it in
this location is just
completely mind-blowing just four years
past her career as a high school art
teacher butler has unveiled her first
show at a major museum and it's at one
of the world's most renowned the art
institute of chicago how would you
describe your art when i first started
making quilts
they were not considered
fine art they were considered craft i
call my work now portrait quilts every
fiber of her life-size portraits is
imbued with meaning from pattern african
fabrics themselves to how they're
patched together i think that
historically
quilt work
craft work had been marginalized because
it was the work of women
and it was a work of people of color it
was considered like a domestic labor
inspired by her mother's and
grandmother's dress making baller
celebrates the craft as well as the
beauty and pride of the black lives they
depict
i love the idea that the images that i'm
making
are looking back out at me
so there's like a intimacy there
and it's a confrontation too so i like
the idea that there's this dialogue
between the subjects and the observers
a conversation resurrecting stories from
the african diaspora often forgotten or
dismissed her subjects real life figures
when i find photos online
or in the databases of black people who
are unnamed
and unknown i feel like
i owe it to them to try to
sort of ascertain what was their
identity the portraits range from those
whose stories are mysterious to central
figures in american history butler
transforms a sepia tone image of harriet
tubman to this a kaleidoscope of vibrant
tones it's on display at the smithsonian
national museum of african american
history and culture
what role does color play in all this
your work is so vibrant and so bright
color is everything to me i i was born
in the 70s so
talk about color technicolor technicolor
turn up the dial
on all of the colors and then you've got
the 70s palette i use the color as a way
to communicate
if i think that somebody seemed to be
more cool more somber i might use shades
of blues and purples
if somebody appears to be like a leader
or
they appear to be more forceful i'm
going to use more intense colors
butler brings her work to life at her
home in new jersey this is where the
magic happens and we're in a dining room
in your house this is your studio this
is my studio i mean they say the kitchen
is the heart of the home
basically the kitchen is the only part
of the home that my family has access to
each figure takes about six weeks to
craft one of butler's most recent works
created over seven months is now
featured at the newark museum of art
so you're about to see the biggest piece
that i've ever made
the piece that took the longest and my
this is my baby
this is stunning
the warmth of other suns depicts black
families migrating to the north in
search of a better life but butler also
takes liberties in taking care of her
subjects
if you look at the original he doesn't
have shoes
but you gave him shoes people wanted to
travel in their very best so if he
didn't have shoes it's because they
couldn't afford them and that's
something that i'd like to give back the
portraits capture the stories of who
people are
and of who they want to be i'm surprised
by how much emotion
this evokes in me
did you want people to have that
reaction when they first see your work
i actually didn't plan on that
but i think that the nature of making
quilts
you have this blanket like object on you
all the time each bit of fabric i've
touched and stitched on so the emotions
from me
are going into the quilt itself
that purposeful intent is now focused on
her next project for the smithsonian the
harlem hell fighters who helped the
united states win world war one it's
going to feature nine soldiers
whose ages range from
19 years old to about 33 and they all
fought in an all black segregated unit
figures from the past timeless as they
come back to life in butler's hands
celebrated and honored across different
generations and backgrounds
i want people
to be able to look at my work and see
the humanity in it
and
let's say
for people who are not black to
understand that we are all human beings
and we have the same wants and desires
loves and fears and for black people i
want them to see themselves and realize
that i recognize who you are and we are
the same
for cbs this morning saturday nancy chen
chicago
powerful well bisa butler's exhibit at
the chicago art institute is open
through monday
this is her book of portraits it's
available through the uh chicago art
institute's museum shop online but you
you venture through this and it's just
an explosion of color and insight and
tales of what she's been through
in the process of making
these beautiful pieces and i just love
what she says you know this is her
moment to shine a light on people that
we still have to keep talking about
these are people these are human beings
and they have lives just like everybody
i love when nancy asks what role does
color play in all this and and beast
says color's everything to me yeah and
just the vividness of the colors in all
of these pictures absolutely beautiful
stunning and she looked like she you had
said this it looked like she could have
been
literally in her own work yeah she was
adorned yeah